bruno margolle bonjour bienvenue sur
l'antenne de la matinale de rtl france
merci d'être avec nous ce matin
alors on a entendu les pêcheurs
britannique qui se sentent trahis vous
côté français vous êtes soulagé ça
aurait pu être bien pire tout à fait ça
fait quatre ans une vie que le
feuilleton continue donc à huit jours on
va dire à une semaine de la fin période
de transition
c'est quand même inespéré d'avoir un
deal et franchement on est soulagé même
si cet accord cet accord est encore à
avoir bien bien déterminée mais c'est
quand même un soulagement
aujourd'hui ans et 25% de moi finalement
de pêche dans les eaux britanniques on
sait que les bateaux on sait que les
structures ne sont pas forcément les
mêmes
est ce qu'il y aura des pêcheurs qui
seront plus les et d'autres ceux par
exemple qui pèche plus près des côtes
anglo normandes en fait de l'hélicoptère
a dû à la diminution de 10 missions de
25 portaient ces enclos bali t il va y
avoir des commandes des quotas il doit
être plus important des dix missions de
quotas tels que le maquereau le
maquereau sur les cinq ans ça va faire
une diminution de près de 40 % de
diminution de quotas donc il va y avoir
des bateaux quitteront plus qu'ils sont
plus sur ces espèces lors qu'ils vont
être qu'ils vont être plus toute attache
donc il va falloir bien entendu rôles
qui mentionnait notre flotte de manière
à pouvoir pérenniser nos entreprises
alors voyez justement ce que disait
samedi la ministre de la mère annick
girardin chez nos confrères de france
inter on regarde et on réagit ensuite
ses 171 millions d'euros que nous
pêchons chez nos voisins britanniques
aujourd'hui 25% de moins environ 42
millions
il va en manquer c'est pour cela qu'il
ya ce plan d'accompagnement budgétaire
et aussi de restructuration de formation
de ceux qui sortiront de cette filière
oui il y aura un peu de casse mais oui
l'etat sera là un peu de casse donc
qu'est ce que ça veut dire concrètement
moins de pêcheurs qui vont embarquer
du chômage à prévoir les licenciements
quand on est mis devant nous pour
redimensionner notre notre flottille
pour adapter notre flottille c'est un
franc l'investissement peut dire ce qui
est aujourd'hui les bateaux qui n'ont
pas leur intériorité qui peuvent qui va
le faire un bateau neuf aujourd'hui
c'est compliqué pour aller dans les eaux
britanniques parce que ils n'auront pas
d'antériorité donc tout ça il faut le
prendre en ligne de compte c'est le but
dit franchement c'est un frein à
l'investissement et il va y avoir oui
les gens qui y avoir certainement un
plan sorti du lot la psf de manière à
accompagner les gens qu'ils arrivent
qu'ils veulent quand ils veulent arrêter
le métier mais bon il ya des
possibilités de reconversion
certainement sur d'autres espèces comme
la copie saint georges par exemple dans
le détroit du pas de calais pour il ya
la ressource bien entendu et il ya il ya
le marché donc il y avait possibilité
mais c'est limité alors vous lisiez on
va entrer dans une période de transition
qui est prévu jusqu'en 2026 dans cinq
ans et demi des négociations avec les
britanniques sur la pêche sont prévues
tous les ans est-ce que c'est rassurant
finalement ben disons que là pendant
cinq ans et demi on est à peu près
rassurer à peu près après les cinq ans
et demi ça avec beaucoup plus compliqué
bien entendu parce que ça sera renégocié
tous les ans donc tous les ans les
britanniques donneront le droit d'accès
ou pas aux bateaux aux bateaux de
l'union européenne et là ça va être
compliqué donc on a quand même la
possibilité de 2 par rapport au marché
il faut dire que le roi les britanniques
ils ont quand même assez au marché
européen qui représente des milliards
des milliards d'euros alors un plan
d'accompagnement va être détaillée dans
très peu de temps on le sait déjà
une des zèbres qui peuvent aller jusqu'à
30000 euros en fonction de la dépendance
dans les eaux britanniques
c'est une bonne chose pour vous trente
mille euros c'est je sais pas si c'est
un coup de fusil seulement ou si c'est
par année c'est tout ça reste à
déterminer
depuis depuis l'accord qui est arrivé
juste la veille de noël bien entendu
nous nous avons des réunions depuis
depuis hier sans arrêt pour bien étudier
cet accord et de manière à en sortir les
conclusions qui vont bien de pour
adapter nos flottille doit effectivement
un rapport très dansant il fait plus de
2000 pages est-ce que déjà vous
l'étudier depuis hier vous avez pu
identifier des interrogations des points
éventuellement d'achoppement des
interrogations que je vous disais des
bateaux qui n'ont pas d'antériorité
entre 2012 et 2016 sauf s'ils sont
remplacés depuis ce temps là ils peuvent
continuer à aller dans les 6 12 milles
en l'occurrence dans les hauts de france
à nous bien sûr il y a que dix sept
mille qui nous séparent de commandes et
îles britanniques
elle la france si on nous retire les 6
12 milles c'est compliqué tout le monde
va se rabattent donc ça c'est déjà un
point qui est important après les cinq
ans et demi je sais pas si ça sera
maintenue faut savoir que dans le
détroit du pas de calais il n'y a pas
que les chalutiers ou les fileyeurs les
les les les gens qui font du des
crustacés voilà c'est ça ouais ça va
être compliqué les conséquences pour les
consommateurs est ce qu'on doit
s'attendre à une hausse de prix du
poisson avec après ces négociations
après cet accord je pense pas dans
l'immédiat qu'il ya une augmentation du
prix du poisson comme je vous dis les
droits des droits d'accès samson il n'y
a pas de droits de douane et puis de
taxes sur les produits qui a drogué et
britannique pour que je pense pas que
dans l'immédiat sera d'ailleurs une
différence de prix merci beaucoup bruno
margollé d'avoir été ce matin avec nous
en direct sur rt france je rappelle vous
êtes le président de la fed au passé la
fédération des organisations de
producteurs de la pêche artisanale
m